jusqu'ici on a beaucoup donné la part le
new yorkais mais on ignore comment en
dehors de manhattan les habitants ont
réagi en ce dimanche isabelle le
vestiaire s'est rendu à la messe dans le
new-jersey de l'autre côté du vote sonne
le trou béant du world trade center n'en
finit pas de fumée sur les premières
hauteurs de nude josé le village de
weatherford encaisse le choc
cette paroisse saint georges a perdu un
de ses anciens prêtres et quelques
fidèles dans la catastrophe
nous sommes dans un quartier italien
particulièrement croyant folie c'est
1941 le 7 décembre
pearl harbor qui recommence je pense
qu'on va mettre longtemps à s'en
remettre dans la bonne direction
le président a fait son travail le
congrès lui a donné des moyens
il ne s'agit pas de simple vengeance ce
qu'ils ont fait aux états unis n'est pas
pardonnable
qu'est ce que vous redoutez maintenant
je ne sais pas j'espère que ça ne va pas
recommencer les américains attendaient
ce premier dimanche après la catastrophe
pour trouver le réconfort religieux dont
ils sont très coutumier pour réfléchir
ensemble prier et dans cette église
franciscaine peut être trouver des
raisons de pardonner
émotion collective tristesse compassion
mais aussi solidarité tous les serments
du pays comme celui du frère bryan ont
rendu hommage aux pompiers policiers
infirmiers secouristes qui ont péri et à
ceux qui luttent encore
bon
c'est terrible d'avoir la haine on va à
l'église pour trouver la paix et on a le
coeur plein de haine c'est terrible
alors on prie pour trouver la sérénité
la religiosité le patriotisme des
américains se conforte dans ses temps de
douleur et de ripostes annoncé chacun
ici qu'ont déjà avec la guerre